[Musique]
bonjour nous allons donc reprendre notre
cours de mathématiques et aujourd'hui
nous allons commencer un nouveau
chapitre sur les fonctions à variables
multiples mervent nous allons corriger
devoir de maison donc je vous invite
donc à ouvrir vos cahiers
je vais passer je commençais par là et
contrôler major nos déboires le nom nom
de ceux qui n'auront pas faire leurs
exercices
ça vous dit quelque chose
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs oui on
est tous passés par là les moments où
ces profs de sciences de physique de mad
devenaient des terroristes oui je
passais par là aussi et je pense que
comme vous vous aurez mais qui vous
disent tout simplement avec ses
histoires de poussée d'archimède les
caussinus les sinus ce que vous voudrez
pu faire dans la vie ce que vous
pourriez fabriquer comment utiliser tout
ça pour aider moment à la maison
moi j'aurais tout simplement aimé qu'il
m'apprenne à faire
un robot qui me dise en quoi caussinus
sinus les angles et tout ça en quoi m
sont utiles pour faire ce robot qui me
disent quand je suis ici et que ce robot
il bouge pour marcher ce qui se passe en
de téléphoner et mon robot qui me disent
quand je veux faire coucou au public ce
qu'il faut faire
ça aurait été plus simple serait plus
intéressé mais bon c'était pas le cas
alors j'ai continué mon parcours je
voulais développer la technologie pour
le milieu agricole et après mon bac j'ai
fait une formation en énergies
renouvelables
après environnement et qualité de vie
ça n'a rien à voir avec le robot oui je
sais pourquoi parce que pour pouvoir
faire la technologie
j'arrivais pas à trouver les gens pour
m'aider
il y avait personne qui comprenait ce
que vous voulez faire au fond ou qui
savait comment transformer cette
caussinus
et tout ça et faire mon projet alors
aujourd'hui quand on me demande de me
présenter je me dis je dis tout
simplement
bah je suis vous il faut le bébé je suis
un mec heures je ferme tout je fabrique
des choses et c'est ce que je fais
donc j'avais remarqué aussi par rapport
à mon projet qui avait beaucoup de
jeunes dans cette situation qui avait
beaucoup de connaissances vous qui savez
pas comment les utiliser ou qui ont des
diplômes qu'ils savaient pas quoi ça
pourrait leur servir dans la vie
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
concrètement dans leur communauté alors
j'ai lancé le meilleur space et côté
clab l'espace où on accompagne des
porteurs d'idées pour créer des
prototypes et on a même nous mêmes en
récitant du matériel informatique usagé
féminin prime en droits des imprimantes
3d qui a servi à imprimer les pièces de
ce robot alors à force on apprend
beaucoup
mais ce n'est pas que de la technologie
il ya là musri
là comme on peut le voir sur cette photo
il ya un ingénieur génie électrique et
un environnementaliste basketteurs ya
quelqu'un qui a fait les assurances
armelle il ya caroline quel designer ya
un docteur le dr izzie et ils étaient
tous là faut qu'on récite des palettes
et qu'on fabrique des tabourets pour le
make up his et c'est comme ça qu'on
partage cette passion qu'on amène les
gens à trouver concrètement ce qui peut
faire comment il peut découvrir de
nouveaux
comment il peut utiliser tout ce qu'ils
apprennent à l'école c'est de bonnes
idées
c'est des défis intéressants qu'on se
lancer et en 2017
il ya eu un grand défi il ya l'ambassade
des états unis qui voudraient
transformer sa le projet moulin au début
ça ressemblait à un tas de ferraille
une voiture qui n'avait pas servir à
grand chose mais on s'y croyait on veut
faire un laboratoire mobile
on aimerait aller dans les écoles avec
on se dit c'est intéressant et des
meilleurs on va voir une composition
on a été contacté pour cela et donc du
coup on a pensé ainsi ça a l'air joli
pas vrai oui mais attend de le voir
parce qu'en vrai c'est plus mieux et
ensemble on a fait la mi-2010 d'ailleurs
qu'on a proposé équipés avec des
panneaux solaires donc fortement
l'énergie
les places pour avoir des ordinateurs
l'évier pour rincer les éprouvettes et
ou de quoi stocker c'était fun je
voulais vous mets
plus fort encore c'est qu'on a conduit
avec le mollah ben parce qu'on a compris
que ce n'était pas seulement les jeunes
qui avait besoin qu'on leur dise quoi
faire avec les sciences c'était pas
seulement ceux qui avaient déjà fini
leur formation à l'université
c'était surtout à la base et donc avec
le moulin on sait qu il un peu partout
je suis au nord du togo
on va là les villages on va dans des
écoles ou comme moi y la salle de classe
est pas construite on signe oui à une
centaine d'élèves
mais tout comme moi tout comme vous je
pense qu'à ce moment là ils ont besoin
qu'on leur dise avec les sciences tu
peux faire ceci pour leur communauté a
donc du coup on est pris dans le
mouvement et on fait plus avec le mollah
ben on va même dans des orphelinats où
il ya des enfants en situation
difficultés des enfants sans parents
semble banni des enfants rejetés par
leurs parents ça c'est à sokodé dans
l'ordre dans la région centrale où on
est allé à creuser togo une ong qui
récupère les enfants dans cette
situation et e
pour eux c'est l'opportunité de voir
pour la première fois une imprimante 3d
fait au togo par des frères à eux pas
les extraterrestres des gens qui ont
pris du matériel informatique usagé qui
ont fait une imprimante
et qui leur montre un robot ce robot que
vous ne devoir qui a été imprimé à 10
cette imprimante 3d pour la première
fois il y en a qui touche à l'ordinateur
et qu'ils voient que c'est possible
comme nous avec l'ordinateur d'apprendre
a faim on peut tous d'apprendre à faire
des robots d'apprendre à faire les
imprimantes 3d
et cette tournée on les appelle des
tournées steam steam ça veut dire quoi
rassurez vous c'est pas une nouvelle
marque de chewing gum sims et sciences
technologies ingénierie à et
mathématiques
donc ces tensions discipline que vous
connaissez déjà mais la broche steve
c'est la prochain trail et kehl on va
vers ces élèves là et à travers du
design qui t'as pensé à pensée créative
pour ses critiques on les amène à
développer des solutions sur place en
utilisant les sciences en leur montrant
concrètement ce qui se passe quand
j'appuie je touche l'écran de mon
portable ce qui se passe et le message
arrive au niveau du robot il reçoit le
message qu'est ce qui se passe ce
message il contient coin si je lui dis
bonjour est-ce qu'il va répondre d'un
gilardino il faut programmer
il faut leur apprendre comme vous quand
vous étiez bébé vous compreniez pas la
file que vous voyez autour de vous les
comparez et petit à petit vous avez
appris à parler à communiquer et lui
faut élu lui apprendre une langue et
communiquer avec lui à travers et ça
c'est la programmation tout simplement
et ça si vous avez de bonnes notions
mathématiques de bonnes notions logique
et tout pour le faire mais même sans ça
avec internet aujourd'hui après hostile
vous pouvez aussi apprendre ça et je
leur apprends là c'est ce que je faisais
et ça c'était la semaine passée dans les
plateaux ou après l'avoir monde et se
montrer ce robot cela appris comment
faire juste hamon
avec un bras je leur ai demandé ça c'est
quoi
ils m'ont dit des articulations ils
connaissent en fait c'est justice a pas
quoi faire avec
alors je leur dis oui avec les
articulations pour ferrand un robot on
met les moteurs à la place et ses roues
sans moteur on leur dit faites l angle
fait l angle et on programmait des
actions alors après ça ils ont compris
ce qu'ils pouvaient faire
je vis en utilisant la notion d' angles
qu'ils auront pris en mathématiques
c'est intéressant pas vrai nom s'arrête
pas là caen - change le banni mais cet
atelier dans d'autres salles il ya
d'autres collègues qui font de l'art qui
leur montre ce qui se passe
travail au microscope il y en a pour la
première fois de leur vie
moi jamais je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de
voir ça la fa lui le mot là aussi pour
moi de voir les possibilités rouge
brique ou lot de showkhi se troubler eu
avec le moral ils ont cette chance de le
voir et donc de commencer déjà à penser
à ce qu'il peut apporter à notre société
après en clôture fait une petite
discussion avec moi je fais
particulièrement où je leur parle des
innovateurs au togo je n'a pas de
monsieur l'eau bout avec une faux faux
mise du fait qu'il a fallu qu'ils
observent ses parents la difficulté de
plein fouet je pense que dans cette
salle sera difficile de trouver une
personne qui n'aime pas le faux pas vrai
ouais
j'adore le foot
et donc des exemples comme ça ça les
motive ça leur permet de rêver de penser
à développer des solutions pour leur
communauté pour le togo pour l'afrique
et pour le monde
pourquoi remuer ses enfants a pensé à
utiliser ces sciences à développer des
idées pour l'avenir justement parce que
justement parce que si on était à bord
d'un avion le pilote nous aurait dit
attention bouclez vos ceintures
pour gagner vos places rentrons dans une
zone de défis oui la venue nous réserve
beaucoup de défis il y en a qu'une voie
ont déjà si on veut se lancer
aujourd'hui à lisser les défis qui nous
attendent les défis de demain
je pense que on va y passer un bon
moment
ah ouais moi il y en a qu elles on peut
penser il ya nord auquel on doit pas
penser
et justement il faut je pense qu'il faut
préparer des gens pour ces défis
et quand on pense aux hommes quand je le
vois moi il maintenir la confiance je
pense que lui il peut tout faire
je pense que si vous lui donniez c'est
pas un défi de la société il vous dira
oui je vais faire quelque chose et il va
apporter sa pierre à la résolution de
de cette situation et c'est pourquoi je
pense que à travers la culture mais
coeur à travers l'éducation steam
nous pouvons faire des meilleurs
challenger parce que pour des défis pour
des challenge
il faut déjà les coeurs il faut des gens
prêts à défier la situation pour
apporter des solutions
oui mais pour ça il faut beaucoup de
choses et il faut pas forcément un robot
comme celui qu'on a là il faut pas
forcément gars comme moi il voit il faut
des gens comme vous qui vont leur
montrer d'ordonner le connaissances leur
donner des savoir faire partager avec
eux ce qui se passe au boulot papa qui
revient je suis docteur alors et les
cours julien savoye à papa les
mathématiques c'est compliqué c'est vrai
ça l'était aussi pour moi mais faut que
tu t'accroches je peux t'aider
et oui il faut ça aussi et ça c'est un
dj set est ce que les anglophones
appellent exposure il faut qu'il soit
dans un environnement où il vivra où ils
sont encouragés ou en leur monde qui
peut faire de grandes choses
et à travers tout ça je pense qu'ils
sont amenés à développer des qualités
des bonnes bonne qualité et avec ça ils
ont une bonne attitude pour pouvoir
changer le monde à portée du changement
positif dans leur communauté
et ça c'est ensemble que nous le faisons
il faut pas forcément des meilleurs
comme moi mais vous aussi et sans jus
convaincu alors le mot lab continue son
petit bout de chemin et pour ceux qui
sont intéressés qu'ils aimeraient vivre
comment ça se passe avec le malade
nous serons le 16 et le 17 février
nous allons faire avec monsieur mike
bryan de la frontière du ghana à la
frontière il a conduit de bnn sur mike
préfère une marche et tout au long nous
allons faire des activités donc à 7.2
vous pourrez passer voir et voir comment
avec vous à la maison avec vos frères
vos enfants ou soeurs beaux nièce vous
pouvez aussi contribué à faire des gros
challenger pour demain merci je suis aux
airs floride
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]